are you afraid of death
nah i'm not afraid of death
i'm not i'm not trying to see it you
know
i'm not rushing that nowhere near me
right because all i know is life
right my life is living
um you know i read a lot of ancient
texts people probably know about me and
i love one of the great teachers named
bodhidama
uh hey and there was a
thing written and you know one of the
uh
books of his or one of the teachings of
his and the question somebody asked him
similar question you know you're scared
of death or what are you gonna be
after you die
and his answer was i don't know
he had answers to everything
but he's like i don't know this oh he
doesn't know that so yeah because i
haven't died yet yeah
well the uncertainty to some people is
terrifying not knowing what's on the
other side of the door
yeah i mean especially when you're young
you know as a kid
fear
permeated my life
you know i mean you know i was actually
watching horror movies and
i believed in all type of uh
supernatural things that could uh can
happen i thought i saw things as well
and uh
you know whether it was being projected
for my own mind or whether it was there
visible to me i don't know right
um
but
life is beautiful
and if we have it
and we should use it all the way to the
last job
realizing the mortality
the the gift your mother gave to you is
realizing the immortal
and in so doing help you realize that
life is beautiful
you